[Music]
I'm Christopher Hyde and this week we're
talking about the Oh sake homie Wazza
and what the OS a Comey was it is so the
OCA call me woz is a set of pinning and
takedown methods that we use in Aikido
it's not the premier idea of the style
right so if you look at the forms then
most of the forms resolve and either a
throw or a pin so it would make you
think that Aikido must either be about
projecting or about controlling but the
problem is those are the things that
have gone worse like I have to do those
things so that's why I'm either pinning
or throwing like that because things
have gotten so bad that I get locked
down in that and the basic Aikido theory
that we use we would really like to do
nothing to anyone we would like to just
get away from them and not hurt them and
them not hurt us and everything worked
out well unfortunately that's always not
gonna play out that way so oseco me woz
is a series of techniques that allow us
to take care of situations when we have
the opportunity that arises a lot of
people like to criticize Aikido
techniques or Aikido students like to
try to change the techniques because
it's like oh you know I know better ways
to pin than Aikido teaches I he teaches
dumb ways to pin but the truth is IQ
pins are all based around the idea of
pinning with autonomy versus pinning
with security
so all pins of course have to have some
security to them but I feel puts a
premium on the autonomy and doesn't put
a premium on the security if the
security is what you put a premium in in
modern style jiu-jitsu or any grappling
style where the idea is to absolutely
hold someone at all costs and Aikido we
don't have the absolutely hold them at
all costs mentality instead we have the
idea of I want autonomy while being able
to pin this guy if I cannot pin him
that's fine because of the autonomy I've
afforded myself I can always still get
out of there so in this video we're
going to talk a little bit about the
autonomy and how that works
I'm gonna call Josh in here and we're
gonna show you some stuff okay so the
first part we talked about pins and
align to the pins look the way they look
is we have to always account for weapon
arm control so there's gonna be a weapon
the reason we're pinning this guy is
probably because he was armed this we've
got to control that weapon arm first my
second objective being the second hand
over our
though overall these things is my
autonomy so understand what I'm pinning
someone there are two kind of priorities
I could have I can have a priority of
security or I could have a priority of
autonomy so security means I want to
make sure he doesn't move at all
autonomy means that I want to make sure
I can move whenever I want so my
autonomy and IQ depends is actually my
number one and I'm gonna show you why
this is so let's say I'm holding Josh
down here in a classic Aikido pin okay
this is a classic I could open like this
now what I want Josh to do is Josh I
want you to hold me I'm gonna try and
get out of this so I'm gonna think
there's trouble and I'm gonna get up and
I'm gonna walk away Josh I want you to
hold me when I do that you're a jockey
okay now I moved out it's slick and slow
as I possibly could
with with any kind of reason and he
still wasn't able to get me right so I
was really able easily to escape that
position right okay now I'm gonna have
Josh lay on his stomach for me okay now
we're gonna do say I cross body position
like this so you might see in if you're
doing some kind of pinning combination
from wrestling or a modern jujitsu so
this is side mountain in Brazilian
jiu-jitsu
okay now Josh I'm gonna try to get up
and I want you to keep me here okay you
ready okay so fun more work right if
josh is right on it I might not ever get
up right so this might seem like a silly
thing to worry about because it's like
well I'm holding him so why would he
ever hold me there let me explain why
this might happen so let's say I got
this guy in out like him and I hear his
friend arising and so I go oh I better
get out of here to the Friends of riding
okay
the friends on top of me now before I
can get out of there let's look at the
same thing from an Aikido style pin so
I'm here like this I'm paying this guy
to go always friends coming
okay now we're gonna set that up I'm
inside Maya and Maya is gonna get to say
go so she's gonna have the advantage on
me as to when she goes we're gonna set
her just a few feet away we're right
side the boom safety distance here we're
gonna see if I can get out of there
before
Joshua's gonna do is absolute best to
keep me here when mine says go she's
gonna do her best to get me go so you
can see even with the advantage towards
Maya she got to pick when she went I
could get out of there before Maya could
get in let's try it the other way
actually it's a face this weight
something easy to leave you out this
round you guys fast like in what have
you ready mine go
okay so we're really trying to get out
of there and it's nearly impossible for
me to do that you have to account for
your own autonomy why is that important
Aikido because in Aikido the objective
is there's always going to be multiple
people who are better at fighting than
we are right we just got to escape that
can't fight with this guy I was
fortunate enough to be able to hold this
guy down but someone else came to fifth
graders in a classroom one's got a knife
I'm holding him down for the princess of
the show up and help me meanwhile
another fifth grader I didn't know that
is attacking with the knife I have to be
able to exit the position quickly you
always have to account for autonomy and
that's what IQ pins do autonomy an IQ is
absolutely essential I'm Christopher
Hine thanks for watching